vous remercie d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors l' agence nationale de
sécurité sanitaire préconise une
utilisation restrictif du glyphosate
uniquement si aucune autre alternative
chimique n'est possible c'est un point
positif pour l'environnement c'est
surtout vous me pardonnez l'expression
idiot parce que voilà maintenant trente
ans que je travaille sur le rwanda
j'ai bien aimé que votre journaliste
soit devant les bidons de roundup et la
communication de monsanto et la
communication américaine a très bien
marché parce que même emmanuel macron
appelle cela le glyphosate
en fait il y a des poisons cacher nous
l'avons montré à plusieurs reprises à
l'intérieur des bidons de roundup qui
sont eux les vrais cancérogènes et ce
n'est pas le glyphosate et qui sont des
dérivés de pétrole des hydrocarbures
polycycliques aromatiques et des métaux
lourds comme l'arsenic dont est mort
sans doute le jardinier de wayne johnson
pour cela
monsanto a été condamné aux états unis
pour malveillance par un juge est donc
aujourd'hui nous connaissons la vérité
bien sûr qu'il ya des alternatives
vous l'avez dit dans votre reportage les
bio en utilisent et puis bayer lui-même
qui à la compagnie qui a racheté
monsanto qui elle-même sans doute fait
des fraudes de la même manière à
commercialiser des rames d'absents
glyphosate avec du vinaigre dedans et
nous venons de montrer que
le vinaigre marche très bien tout seul
mais par contre dans les bidons de bayer
il y allait même cancérogènes
il y avait dans l'évident avec du
glyphosate des hydrocarbures
polycycliques aromatiques
nous venons de montrer cela avec gérald
singer et nous publions cela dans une
grande revue ces jours ci alors vous
l'avez dit et puis de toute façon c'est
avéré le glyphosate est cancérigène et
puis il existe six ddd alternative alors
pourquoi est-ce qu'on s'obstine à
utiliser le glyphosate emmanuel macron
avait fait de la sortie du glyphosate
une de ses promesses de campagne une
nouvelle fois c'est une promesse qu'il
ne tiendra pas pourquoi d'après vous
alors comme je lé précisé ce n'est pas
le glyphosate est cancérogène mais les
produits qui sont avec dans le bidon et
qui ne sont pas déclarés c'est une
fraude à la déclaration et c'est cela
qui est très grave et c'est pour ça
qu'il ya un débat qu'on ne comprend pas
en fait les pesticides sont faits avec
des résidus de pétrole
c'est de la pétrochimie et ses produits
sont extrêmement cancérogènes et de
glyphosate est un faux nez qui sert à
breveter l'ensemble de ces résidus de
pétrole qui sinon ne sommes pas on ne
donne pas autant d'autorisation à des
résidus de pétrole cancérogènes donc il
il sert si vous voulez d'alibi c'est un
peu comme quelqu'un qui n'aurait pas
commis un crime et qu'on met en avant
pour ne pas faire emprisonner les
réelles coupable qui ne sont pas
déclarés et donc nicolas hulot emmanuel
macron le savez nous avons trouvé cela
dès 2018 mais ils ne réagissent pas
parce que ça remettrait en cause tout le
processus de fabrication des pesticides
donc cesser purement la question est
purement pécuniaire si je plusieurs on
parle d'argent uniquement dans ce
dossier là en fait que vous savez
l'argent vient des impôts des gens c'est
à dire que la politique agricole commune
est une façon de subventionner
l'agriculture intensive avec cet argent
les agriculteurs achètent des herbicides
à base de glyphosate comme le roundup
est ainsi c'est de l'argent privé
l'argent des gens l'argent des impôts
qui est rendue publique qui va à aux
multinationales et qui les rend les
multimilliardaires les huit premières
d'entre elles ont plus de la moitié de
la fortune mondiale
ce que nous avons montré au niveau
scientifique et que cette c'est une
immense mafia qui commence aux états
unis avec monsanto et qui se termine
avec bailleur en europe cela ils le
savaient et c'est pour ça que la firme a
été condamné bayer jusqu'à 10 milliards
a dû donner à cent mille patients cet
été aux états unis et nous savons qu'il
y avait ces poisons cacher mais là
l'information des agences de
communication ne le dit pas où nous
l'expliquent pas alors comment on fait
pour se débarrasser de ces
enfin si mais qu'est ce qu'il faudrait
passer par l'union européenne est ce que
ces lieux qui doit trancher obliger les
pays à s'en débarrasser vous pensez
qu'il peut y avoir une harmonisation à
l'échelle européenne
ce sera une solution il ya déjà une
harmonisation à l'échelle européenne
pour autoriser tous ces produits à base
de pétrole je pense qu'il faut que ce
soient les méthodes agricoles et les
subventions qu'ils doivent changer en
fait si on change les subventions et
qu'on va vers une agriculture plus
naturel avec des produits bio on
arrivera à changer sinon le système ne
changera pas à la pétrochimie attire la
pétrochimie et aujourd'hui nous avons
toutes les alternatives possibles
beaucoup l'exploit
nous avons posé par exemple les résidus
drones date dans le vin et c'est vrai
que le vin et le plus pesticides et des
produits quand il n'est pas bio et nous
avons trouvé du glyphosate
en fait il ya beaucoup de vins bio qui
s'en passe complètement et qui ont
beaucoup plus d'arômes et de la
viticulture est quelque chose de
symbolique parce que c'est là la vigne
c'est la plante la plus traitée au monde
donc nous avons les moyens de faire
autrement
ça sera le mot de la fin gilles eric
séralini merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions
je rappelle que vous êtes professeur et
auteur de l'ouvragé la sphère roundup
à la lumière des monsanto peppers a
publié aux éditions actes sud
merci